nobody is safe in the world of The
Walking Dead and even whole scenes can
be devoured alive here's the ending
you'll never get to see after 11 Seasons
The Walking Dead is finally resting in
peace the ending the program gave loyal
viewers was nothing if not Bittersweet
while the majority of its regulars
survive Rosita Espinosa Luke and Jules
also come to Walker bites but the rest
of the cast of characters Thrive and
find Family happiness and romance their
settlements grow in peace as well the
show's three upcoming spin-offs are set
up too with Daryl Dixon choosing to roam
the country protecting others Negan
taking off for New York City and Rick
Grimes and Michonne both seen fighting
for their lives miles apart in
completely different locations meanwhile
Judith Grimes and her half-brother RJ
continue to wait at Hilltop for their
parents arrival
you deserve a happy ending too
[Music]
we'll be back
well this was an ending that moved many
in the show's audience it turns out that
the series had planned an entirely
different conclusion to The Adventures
of our Intrepid survivors this ending
inspires hope for the future in a
completely different way from the aired
version and cements the survival of
several Walking Dead characters for an
article published by Insider The Walking
Dead was initially slated to end with a
peek into the future Greg nicotero an
executive producer and director of the
series revealed during a zoom call that
the series finale we saw was not
necessarily the planned series finale he
said there was a scene that we had shot
but when it was decided to put the coda
in we felt like it would conflict with
the Rick and Michonne pit so we took it
out Insider proceeded to confirm this
deleted scene through two members of the
show's crew who preferred to remain
anonymous according to them the final
scene would have taken us back to
Atlanta Georgia specifically Freedom
Parkway down which Rick Grimes rode on
horseback during the Show's first
episode but this time the character is
traveling down the highway are in a van
the scene would be shot in such a manner
as to reveal that these characters are
now grown Judith RJ and their friends
they are just like their parents
apparently on a mission to rescue others
from the apocalyptic Battlefront and
reunify disenfranchised communities it's
hinted that some progress has continued
to be made technologically as well as
the van apparently runs on ethanol this
grown-up version of RJ speaks into a
long Wave radio calling out for any
survivors the episode and the show was
to end with an unseen Survivor speaking
back through the radio so why didn't AMC
and The Walking Dead somewhere in the
far-flung future the crew members
Insider spoke to gave reasons at mesh
with nicoteros it simply didn't serve
the franchise's future health while one
crew member said that ending the show
with new versions of characters we
weren't invested in didn't make sense
another mentioned that the original
ending was simply more fitting
emotionally speaking this all stems from
the fact that the comic book version of
The Walking Dead also ends with a
25-year time Jump the focus of that
final issue is Carl Grimes who of course
did not survive until the show's end in
the television Universe while neither
version places a neat bow on the show
and leaves things open for further
sequels it's understandable why AMC felt
the need to establish Rick and
Michonne's upcoming sequel still it's
hard not to be curious about what could
have been